one of the fun things that you can do in
everyday life is to develop a technique
that I call the love detector and here's
how it works
in everyday life we are constantly
mirroring with our facial expressions
with our body language even with our
breathing and our heart rates people who
we like and the more that we feel like
we really understand somebody we're
really connecting with them we're really
clicking with them the more likely we
are to physically mirror what they're
doing so if you're sitting across from
somebody you're having a meeting you're
having a first date and you notice that
you both have your head kind of tilted
to the same side or maybe you're both
leaning into the table with your head on
hand like this and you haven't done it
on purpose but you notice just in that
instant weight we're really we're
sitting the same way and it'll often
times in my own experience it'll be
really strange position as you're
leaning back with one arm out here
you're like whoa how did we get into
this position well the way it happened
is you are both feeling connected you
feel like you are clicking and so
because of that you're physically
starting to mirror each other
some people would advise you to do this
intentionally to kind of trick the other
person into thinking that wow we're
really getting on look at you mean they
won't consciously know it but their
brain will perceive it I think that's
kind of creepy and really awkward so
instead of using this knowledge to I
don't know maybe manipulate people into
thinking that you're bonding just use it
as a love detector happen to notice in
everyday life when you're physically
mirroring people and that's just a
signal to you it's a clue to you hey
here's somebody that I've really
connected with at a very deep level this
is somebody who would be a great ally a
great collaborator somebody that I
should definitely spend more time
connecting with in the future
you